arie barbara jouent un couple au bord de
la rupture et du coup on va jouer et que
vous les chroniqueurs et vos montures
alors il ya des ruptures qui vont
apparaître
à votre avis quelles ruptures correspond
à quelques chroniqueurs à ce qu'on peut
faire apparaître les rues gelagri une
personne par courrier mail ne l'a jamais
reçu alors par courrier ça a moins vite
ça devait être un télégramme ça doit
être isabelle morini-bosc nom a largué
personne est bel et bien mort alors peut
être j'ai largué une personne par pigeon
voyageur mais n'a jamais reçu moi je
pense ici
moi je ris parce que je connais pas les
réponses si moi j'aurais dit que si mme
kahli pas du tout raté un mois j'aurais
dit gilles verdez parce qu'il a le
physique de quelqu'un qui écrit des
lettres d'amour je vois bien la plume
non non c'est bon alors mais tu n'as
combes et julien oui c'est moi et
barbara les très fort bravo
elle a grillé castaldi l'a bien préparé
l'émission a été très fort dans à la
honda jeu mais alors je me suis fait
largo largué par texto en pleine nuit on
sait que c'est pas isabelle jusqu'à
l'ère be bop
donc je me suis fait larguer par texto
ça casse a dit j'étais sûr je te le jure
i'm here ai'a castaldi ouais parce que
castaldi en pleine nuit je le vois bien
se faire larguer way exactement en fait
je des parts et par quelle femme
alors alors c'était non je souhaitais
c'était ma femme stéphanie femmes
c'était ma femme et ma femme en fait tu
es sahel
je ne peux pas vous le dire mais bon
c'est fait la différence au score 6 4
s'est dégagée par sms
wen ont décru et oui mais en fait je
partais je faisais la matinale sur une
radio rtl2 la réelle de tafer et je
partais assez tôt le matin et je
revenais donc après l'émission et je
faisais une petite sieste
parce que j'étais fatigué et j'ouvre mon
téléphone et j'ai ce texto qui me dit
pas c'est fini bon on a eu des cardeurs
radio ils sont passés bon je te le dire
voilà et non c'était incroyable votre
femme elle doit quitter paraissait ouais
c'est ouf ça c'est ouf mais sans rigoler
je veux que c'est vrai ah ouais flavie
et sans explication banon mais il ya
moyen bien d'ossun j'étais pas j'étais
pas exemplaire un ample mais mes délires
non la prière ou non mais ce n'est pas
le plus parfait des marais mais c'est
vrai que c'est assez violent le texto
pour la basse et charles poncet votre
femme
mais l'eau et non non c'était assez
concis ouais ouais j'en tiens pendant
dix points qui étaient avec toi dans la
marne et parce qu'il n'est pas bien la
ccc ccc fort mais c'est très fort par
exemple se faire larguer par sa femme
par sms était franchement c'était un
assez beau message d'azur ah ouais
j'aime pas ta gueule à garder le moral
c'est beau mais ça on a vécu une belle
aventure
c'était mes jambes ne me portent plus je
sais qu'il prendra son ulti renard je je
je m'en vais porter à l'étouffoir
allemands devaient trouver comment nous
appartient le deuil et chamakh
voilà ok madame c'est fou ça alors
générique gélard y ait quelqu'un à cause
de l'odeur de ses pieds ça c'est
quelqu'un qui sait vraiment femmes
ouais ouais quand ce sens que l aria mme
buffet sur pour ça que je pense à que si
nous faisons ces visas mais non mais non
mais non
alors ces matches on va faire les gros
yeux aux français d'en bas que je le
vois sur madonna s'est voulu me recruter
un jour michel c'est jean-michel massa
doit être à bahia mamie à laquelle il
c'est beau mais c'est vrai on l'a oublié
c'est le signal qu'on va merci l'oublier
c'est sympa mais oh ça va et où est tu
veux tu te donne pas en spectacle offre
alors dénoue non oui c'est vrai que
c'était à deux trois ans voilà j'ai
rencontré un garçon il m'a invité à voir
le foot bon déjà je suis pas fan du foot
mais j'ai dit ok je vais faire un métier
aux fans de foot un moment absolument
pas je me fais un effort je vais parler
à d'autres avec un joueur là allez allez
aaa mais non mais pas une phase aller
badiane et 2f quoi batteuse et vous ça
va à alain qui était passionné par le
foot bref on s'en fout et donc du coup
au final j'y suis allé j'ai fait un
effort j'étais que voir la personne est
installé tout il enlève ses chaussures
et là je me dis mais c'est pas possible
mais ça sent les poubelles ça sent le
fromage les poubelles dit non c'est pas
possible
donc je regarde quand même le match je
prends sur moi et le lendemain je
retourne le voir et appareils la même
chose il en est ainsi je suis moi le mec
en fait il voulait absolument le même
le cas du dpcp des bottes je me suis
fait larguer car mon conjoint avoir
envie de me claquer quand je parlais
laisse moi moi je pense que ces
magistrats max non - ouais moi jle ou
max c max moi je pense non maxime gagné
peu à parler même halo maxime pas fait
une phrase qui bouge on est là bonjour
je suis très content d'être là russie
voudrait c'est moi non c'est vous c'est
moi c'est vous oui voilà de quoi donc
elle avait envie de vous claquez ques
assez d'être diakhaté enchanté avec une
charmante rouquine très propre sur elle
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
tant qu'on est au service des jeunes
m'ont paru en avait plein de points en
commun surtout la bonne bouffe femme et
elle avait une petite particularité ce
qu'elle me voulait m'embrasser que sur
la lèvre du bas elle me replacer à
chaque fois donc je l'embrassé que le
haut donc c'était un petit détail
montrodat on s'entendait bien au bout de
deux mois et années qui arrivent bringue
faussaires on voit même des écrevisses
et matuidi serait bien qu'on soit de
demain non ce pas après demain je peux
pas après après demain je peux pas et au
final elle m'a envoyé un sms en disant
j'ai envie de te claquer quand tu me
parles je ne supporte pas ta voix j'ai
l'impression d'avoir à faire un
présentateur à longueur de journée ah
ouais bah je la comprends voilà c'est ça
et depuis on ne s'est jamais vu il est
reparti avec son ex non ils sont j'étais
très triste
son ex paraît que c'est bernard merci je
m'en fais partie avec jean michel
vernhes